an order for 300 airplanes it's a
game-changer for Airbus giving the
trans-european aircraft maker a leg up
in its never-ending rivalry with US
competitor Boeing China's ji Jinping
signed the deal
during his visit with French president
Emanuel Mahal a move that seems to have
caught EU policymakers a little
off-guard macomb together with German
Chancellor Angela Merkel and EU
Commission President jean-claude Juncker
is cautious about China's multi-billion
euro belt and Road initiative also
called the New Silk Road project it's
aimed at bringing China closer to other
partners internationally and making it a
stronger force in global trade in Paris
the Europeans made a strong appeal to
China to cooperate the mizzen darn
global we have to have trust in
multilateral cooperation and the fact
that everyone wins multilateral
cooperation does not work if one
partners win is another partners loss we
have seen that before and that's why I'm
a firm believer and convinced it's worth
fighting for it tougher to Kim she
responded that the EU and China should
advance together despite distrust that
has recently hindered progress that
includes business with Chinese telecom
equipment maker who away which has been
accused of being in Beijing's pocket the
US has banned the tech giant from its
domestic infrastructure projects the EU
is also currently discussing whether or
not to allow the Chinese company to help
build its new 5g networks in Paris the
European leaders and she set the stage
for the upcoming EU China summit but the
real work will happen behind closed
doors over the course of the next few
weeks Merkel and back home want all 28
EU members to assume a common stance on
China that won't be easy to push through
as some member states are eager to
strike deals with the Asian superpower
last week Italy became the first member
state to become an official partner in
the New Silk Road project when it signed
deals worth over seven billion dollars
including partnerships between
China and the ports of Trieste and Genoa
straight to Paris then where we find a
DW correspondent Rebecca Ritter's
welcome Rebecca so what else have we
learned from this joint press conference
well pretty much what was in that report
is what we got in the press conference
here but I will say that the the mood
was quite convivial so the four leaders
seemed very comfortable with with each
other by all accounts it looked as if
the talks went quite well how much
ground was covered in in just an hour's
meeting it remains to be seen but it
seems that that I think everyone got
what he or she wanted from the meeting
they all spoke of multilateralism that
was the key word being thrown around the
need for a to work together China and
the EU and of course micron spearheading
that unified approach from the EU so a
president macro seems to be giving with
one hand and taking with the other on
the one hand he said thank you very much
for your massive Airbus order but on the
other hand just slow down we need that's
Europe needs to be careful about dealing
with the Chinese yes that is sort of the
confusing message that's coming from
president Michel at the moment as you
say with one hand take very happy to
receive that the sale of that 300 300
Airbus is there and on the other hand
saying we're worried about Chinese
influence but that is the big problem
when we talk about EU China policy is
that nobody really wants to let go of of
the the trade that China has to offer
the slice of the pie everyone wants
their bit China is you use biggest
trading partner and and therefore it's
very important to Europe to all the
individual national nations we that make
up your ante the block as a whole so but
then as you say it's a it's a fine
balance balancing then what you're
saying is too much too much influence in
the region and we want more of a say so
that's where macron comes with his we
need to be forming a united front and
how far along are those plans to form a
united front to get all 28
members singing from the same hymn book
well I think we're really at the
beginning of that a macro did say at the
end of a leaders summit last week that
the era of naivety towards China is over
perhaps we are seeing the beginning of
that era coming being over indeed we
called this sort of emergency summit if
you will to just a little under two
weeks a little over two weeks I'm sorry
until the the big EU summit in April and
then German Chancellor Angela Merkel
also spoke of when the presidency
Germany takes over the presidency of the
EU Chinese EU policy will be you China
relations will be top of the agenda so
perhaps there is some truth to what
micron said and at the summit and that
the era of naivety is over how far we're
into that yet remains to be seen
I'm Rebekah Ritter's in Paris thank you